welcome to this video playing Captain
Picard who changed nationality to
Icelandic okay so let's see a Slav with
queen bee three yeah I like to play it
with Bishop g5 this also III as a as a
possibility but always like the setup
which with rukon do you want it makes it
somewhat difficult would like to to get
e 5 c5 those kind of freeing moves in
let's see what it's doing I've actually
had on the clock doesn't happen often
okay you know taking in one move with
the bishop is tempting but if I take
with the Queen II cannot play b5 at all
okay I guess still taking with the
bishop should be better interesting hmm
yeah I can just trade which is not bad
but I can also try to play it a bit more
interestingly Bishop f4 for example yeah
let's try Bishop f4 a known plan from
games of la cone and drew in stein this
interesting structure here with the
double porn but it ensures why did
excellent central control so the double
porn is not really a big issue black has
problems free in this position with e5
or c5 wider retains very nice activity
yeah hmm what what to do here very
interesting move
I wonder if I should take with the
bishop and just play on on the
weaknesses maybe do that it's not so
always somewhat tricky decision because
of the light squares but yeah the bishop
is on b7 how to set up the pieces now
optimally the knight on c3 is Sam it's
not good maybe I can get it 2 c1 2 d 3
this kind of this kind of maneuver ought
to be three actually would also be nice
I think I'll try that one night to d3
this night to d3 okay is freeing
immediately okay now the long diagonal
interesting the question is if Bishop
takes can you play d4 maybe but he
cannot go queen d 5 this is very
important okay what should i play my I
probably must do this putting it on d4
reliably blockading the pawn or maybe
rook d 493 to increase the pressure yeah
better than blocking and isolated porn
is winning it aha so is just giving the
pawn away for me for control or for
activity of the lower the log diagonal
okay yeah but I can play Knight f5 which
looks good i think threatens on d5 with
97 and here i get i get lots of activity
actually on knife goes back to e3 which
is a very good square night only three
protects the g2 square which is always
tricky i could actually go to 2d six en
this position now probably not 96 is not
really am doing that much yeah so an i
sent game with the extra pond but it's a
double porn and yeah probably check
probably still do that and then the
Queen's get traded or i get i get
centralized after Queen move like Queen
f6f Queen D second with a double attack
on the bishop and Queenie 8 I don't
think he has a very active square now
for the Queen Queen e7 I go queen deform
and take this pretty active position in
the center
okay if i move the Queen now you will
have this check on c1 that's not good
gathered check is a bit bit of a problem
maybe
I will look again here Queen Queen d7 if
I'm my efforts a queen f5 Queen d1s no
problem maybe Queen a 5 on Queen d7
could be an idea I goes to the ATM no it
doesn't okay well I protecting g2 so Oh
made on g7 let's see the know it gets
tricky how do you defend g7 and b7 now I
can I win a bishop here right we never
ate a stone you move to protect the maid
yellen's resign was very helpful that he
allowed that okay I'm clearly better but
how is wide winning not so easy Yeah
right here this is an interesting way to
play black has some problems with with
his pieces maybe you should play slowly
with b6 Bishop e7 here i don't know i
mean have a very nice grip on the on the
position with the Knights I'm not sure
it's a it's interesting I don't think
that this is I'm term I'm term stockfish
a gives black an advantage which I
really cannot believe I mean why should
black be better yeah I know two bishops
and so on but I have a pretty nice
located on c5 best that they can do is
see 5 and this still leaves me with a
good position
this is what stockfish wants to play I
don't really understand why this is so
great I go Quincy three others before
okay so let's say okay I didn't want to
go here now I cannot really increase the
control over c5 this is this is a slight
problem you should see am yeah maybe
maybe maybe this isn't so great I mean
the way it the way it happened was quite
nice deform is an interesting decision I
mean you're very passive if you don't do
it so maybe this was was interesting
check yet here basically just the pawn
up but this this now is so yeah this is
definitely losing Queen f8 was the only
player move but after not 27 widest
white is clearly better he really
probably should have considered this
position a bit more a bit more carefully
and I guess black should be okay yeah
now a bishop t5 is a debatable move
because you weaken the light squares and
these are already a slight issue this is
why I also hesitated a bit with the move
all I have my doubts when I played it
maybe it is better to just drop the
bishop back and go for ideas like this
94 looxcie 195 this is certainly a
playable for white okay thanks for
watching